in a previous video we introduced
ourselves to the idea of average atomic
mass which we began to realize could be
a very useful way of thinking about a
mass at an atomic level or at a
molecular level but what we're going to
do in this video is connect it to the
masses that we might actually see in a
chemistry lab you're very unlikely to
just be dealing with one atom or just a
few atoms or just a few molecules you're
more likely to deal with several grams
of an actual substance so how do we go
from the masses at an atomic scale to
the masses masses of samples that you
see in an actual chemistry lab or in I
guess you could say our scale of the
world well the chemistry Community has
come up with a useful tool they've said
all right let's think about a given
element so say lithium we know it's
average atomic mass is
6.94
6.94 Unified atomic mass unit units per
atom atom of lithium what if there were
a certain number of atoms of lithium
such that if I have that number so times
certain certain number of
atoms then I will actually end up with
6.94 GRS gr of lithium and this number
of atoms is
6.022
476 * 10 to the
23rd power so if you have a sample with
this number of lithium atoms that sample
is going to have a mass of 6.94 g
whatever its average atomic mass is in
terms of unified atomic mass units if
you have that number of the atom you
will have a mass of that same number in
terms terms of
grams now you might be saying is there a
name for this number and there is indeed
a name and it is called avagadro's
number named in honor of the early 19th
century Italian chemist Amadeo avagadro
and in most contexts because you're not
normally dealing with data with this
many significant digits we will usually
approximated as
6.022 * 10 23rd power
now there's another word that it's very
useful to familiarize yourself with in
chemistry and that's the idea of a
mole now what is a mole it is not a
little Mark on your cheek it is not a
burrowing animal actually it is both of
those things but in a chemistry context
a mole is just saying you have this much
of something the word mole was first
used by the German chemist Wilhelm
Oswald at the end of the 19th century
and he came up with the word because of
its relation to molecule now what does
that mean well think about the word
dozen if I say I've got a dozen of eggs
how many eggs do I have well if I have a
dozen of eggs that means I have 12 eggs
so if I say I have a mole of lithium
atoms how many lithium atoms do I have
that means that I have
6.022
1476 time 10^ the 23rd lithium atoms
exact same idea it's just that
avagadro's number is a much Haier of a
number than a dozen